[Music]
[Music]
my baby brother ted
all he cares about is work but he always
remembers to send
inappropriately lavish gifts on special
occasions
good night uncle ted i hope to grow up
and be a success just like you
good night don't you think i'm a little
old for that now
okay i'm afraid tabitha and i are
growing apart
like i did with my brother but you can't
turn back time can you
easy breezy taco peasy boy she can talk
a lot
doesn't last forever but family sure
does hey we get on with this
i miss my teeth what's stressing you out
so much
my dad embarrassed of him oh it's not
bad
i just wanted to be proud of me
everything tim did
every morning when you wake up i will be
there and you
and i will always be brothers
makes me want to make a sad face
[Music]
the formula only lasts 48 hours
we always stick together and that's what
families do
who wants to play shawshank on my signal
unleash
the difference in try and triumph
is just a little oh oopsies i need
options
we did it i guess we did i was talking
about me and precious
oh oh
gross
[Music]
you